Shin Godzilla or Godzilla resurgence or
shin Gojira
it's a Godzilla movie and it has a lot
of titles and I saw it nevertheless it's
one of those I'm gonna go with Shin
Godzilla cuz that's what's on IMDB this
is the 29th Touhou Godzilla film can you
believe that that's kind of crazy it's
not like he's James Bond or anything
Godzilla can't talk he can't have a
conversation with somebody he's just a
fire-breathing monster this is the
twenty-ninth one that's nuts it's the
first Japanese Godzilla in 12 years
since Godzilla final Wars I'm a big fan
of the fire-breathing monster I love
this guy
I have my entire life I grew up with the
original of course it was the American
edited version with Raymond Burr
included called Godzilla king of
monsters I of course enjoyed the 1998
Matthew Broderick Godzilla until I was
old enough to realize how terrible it is
and for whatever reason my favorite when
I was a kid was always King Kong vs.
Godzilla don't ask me why cuz it's
really bad but I loved that shit when I
was a kid so naturally I was really
pumped for this movie because I feel
like this character has been a part of
my entire life
Funimation thanks to them there was a
theatrical run limited so I got to see
it in theaters tonight with English
subtitles the original Japanese language
and this films about a monster called
Godzilla that climbs out of the scene
begins to wreak havoc in Japan and a
bunch of people try to figure out how to
take care of this problem so it's pretty
much the exact same as all the other
Godzilla films this is a soft reboot
it's basically the original Japanese
film taking place in today so we have
kids talking about Godzilla on Twitter
and on YouTube and we have the political
people who are going through these
tweets looking for information maybe
they don't get because people are on the
ground taking photos of Godzilla that
kind of stuff and it's basically the
exact same film as a original one from
the 50s except it's a little more fun
and light-hearted now this could also be
looked at as a sort of tongue-in-cheek
political satire oh the way the Japanese
government works or a commentary on
post-earthquake Japan but a lot of that
is not going to factor in for most
people who don't live in
Japan it's not going to do much for the
storytelling unless you're aware of
these things and you see the connections
so what do they get right about this
movie first off Godzilla
he is so fucking cool in this movie he
looks badass and his appearances are
worth the wait he's got this really cool
orange glow to him and he can just wreak
some serious havoc on Japan and his
sequences are awesome I loved him in
this movie godzilla delivered it was
also cool to hear some of the original
musical cues from back in the day that
were reused in this film as well as some
new music that was also really good as
far as new things go there are two
things I could pinpoint this movie one
being an incredibly chilling and very
effective final shot that I loved and
the other was that Godzilla doesn't
immediately appear as Godzilla he kind
of metamorphosizes in a first I was like
what the fuck is that thing and I was
like I don't know if I feel this right
now but once you see him start to grow
and change and become the Godzilla we
all know and love it reminded me of
Dragon Ball Z there's actually a part
where somebody's like Godzilla is only
in his fourth form and I was like wow
he's Frieza Godzilla's Frieza now so
Godzilla delivered in this movie no
doubt and that's what people are going
to go to this movie see for me
personally I also appreciate things like
a good story and characters people I can
care about something that allows me to
get into the film a narrative a
storyline that I can appreciate maybe
some dramatic depth
yeah that's not in this movie if you've
ever seen a single Japanese Godzilla
film they are basically at least the
solo ones anyway all about Godzilla he
appears and then a bunch of people have
a lot of board meetings a lot of
political discussions a lot of
back-and-forth about what to do and how
to take care of this problem do we send
in the military oh shit that didn't work
let's nuke them you know they're all the
same every solo Godzilla movie is the
same let's face it hardcore fans of
Godzilla I'm with you but they're all
the same come on guys and this movie is
no different it doesn't really take any
chances and I really was disappointed in
the humans in this movie there isn't a
single character I actually tried to sit
down and pinpoint characterization that
was given to anybody and I found one
finally after
thinking about it the young girl in this
film she wants to be president one day
and that's about it honestly everyone
else is just a talking head that is
trying to figure out how to kill
Godzilla now I can see that working in a
film that has a better story or one that
we haven't seen before where it's just
characters constantly trying to figure
out how to deal with a situation it's
really fast-paced this film is not fast
paced though to me anyway because there
is a humongous overabundance of
characters and these characters aren't
really characters I hesitate to even
call them that they're just as I said
Talking Heads the Godzilla scenes are
awesome and really fun but I wish the
story had some more going for it with
the characters somebody I could care
about just throw one of the characters
on street level with Godzilla have them
just be like with Godzilla in a scene
not always in an underground bunker
board room somewhere one guy does look
up once and go that's what he looks like
cuts away to Godzilla once at nighttime
and he walks away that's it I was like
hmm my biggest gripe with this movie is
technically a nitpick but if you are in
Japan watching this film and you speak
the Japanese language and there's no
English subtitles you're going to see a
lot of characters being introduced every
place that you cut to you get text
telling us where it is and not just like
here's a boat in the middle of the ocean
like if they show different parts of
Tokyo they're like this part of Tokyo
sub district this part of Tokyo
underground division and stuff like that
every person that walks onto screen gets
a name imprinted now if you're in Japan
watching that as I said you get one
white burnt end text in Japanese
characters that could maybe be tolerable
but in America not only do you get that
white burnt in character text you get
yellow English text telling us what
those words say overlaid over the white
text and the English subtitles from the
people who are speaking so sometimes 75%
of the screen is filled with text it's
kind of annoying actually and they they
use it so much they really do like every
character and there's like a hundred
characters that come on screen this
movie it's like there's the defense
secretary of this this woman works for
this place I'm like I don't need to know
all this it's a lazy form of
storytelling rather than finding more
creative ways to let us know about these
characters ever
comes on screen they just throw some
text in front of us those are my biggest
gripes with shin Godzilla as someone who
grew up with his character I loved
seeing him wreak havoc the special
effects were actually pretty good for a
Japanese live-action film it's directed
by the man behind Neon Genesis
Evangelion and Gunbuster it was really
cool to see someone from anime take on
something like this and overall he added
some really really impressive visuals to
Godzilla he felt humongous there were
some beautiful aerial shots some very
chilling moments in which Godzilla just
lays waste to things and I enjoyed that
aspect of this movie and I think that
fans of the Japanese Godzilla films in
particular will also really like this
film especially since most of those
people didn't really enjoy the gareth
edwards godzilla so they'll probably go
to this and be satisfied but there is a
lot of political babbling and talking
and really boring cardboard cut-out
characters and that was a disappointment
to me i'm going to give shin godzilla a
b- it does what it should despite the
fact that it is sort of a very
unimaginative soft reboot that we have
seen before I was ok with it because
it's Godzilla I don't like seeing them
tear ass through a city guys thank you
so much as always for watching this film
is still going to be in a limited
theatrical run for a while so if you
want to check it out in theaters you can
probably find it near you also I want to
let you know that my sponsorship with
audible is still going on
if you go to audible.com slash Chris you
can get a free 30-day trial from an
amazing selection of hundreds of
thousands of audiobooks I personally
love that they have all the Star Wars
books on this website that's big for me
because I love them and if you go to
audible.com slash Chris as I said you
get that free 30-day trial and you can
choose from so many different things to
put on your mp3 player your tablet and
you can read books on the go and it's
very convenient for people who don't
always have the time to sit down and
read so please do check out audible.com
slash Chris for that free 30-day trial
and thank you very much to audible for
continuing to sponsor my videos guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]